time for another code review what's up
guys my name is welcome back to the
series where you guys send me your code
and projects and other things that I
never asked for and I take a look at
them and give my thoughts on them so
today we have a 2d C+ Plus game egg 9
I'm not really sure what an egg n is but
perhaps some of you who are a little bit
more experienced than me can drop a
comment below LOL iio is the per is like
the name of this account I've hidden the
email address as I usually do but that's
a fantastic start strong start I've been
working on my game engine for about
2,000 hours now and I really would
appreciate it if a professional could
review my code this project is going
into my portfolio so roast me as much as
you can I don't know if you want to ask
me to roast you as much as I can but on
the other hand the thing that I'm
immediately thinking about by the way if
you guys thought I was going to review
Co today no no no no no we're going to
be reviewing this email today roast
along with I've been working on this for
about 2,000 hours like how how mean of a
person do you think I am because I just
don't even know if I'm capable of that
it's a bit of a ju to position here
because this is a lot of work and I
don't want to be mean to you about all
of your effort so I'm going to try and
be gentle I'd like you to look out code
structure the way I handle the project
of the user managing the Sprites and how
you would so and how you would sew
things also the engine won't work if you
don't have the engine as well as the
project in the sea dire Factory oh buddy
you won't need a build system or
anything just hit build in vs that's not
necessarily a good thing but also the
engine won't work if you don't have the
engine as well the user project in the
sea directory how am I going to be nice
about this this is a strong start I mean
to be completely fair this is this is
I'm just going to apologize in advance
please try and take any advice and
criticism that I give you and for all of
you watching who didn't write this
project because I have a feel feeling
that we're in for a ride this is like
the biggest disclaimer ever I'm not
trying to be malicious I'm going to try
my best to give you helpful and
actionable advice that will improve your
programming so let's let's take a look
at this okay so this is the GitHub
repository the link will be in the
description below so if you would like
to take a look at it for yourselves you
definitely can do that project is a
simple 2D game engine using sfml dear am
goey and I don't know what this is Renee
sure I actually don't know what that is
uh it looks like it's got quite a lot of
features I mean if you put 2,000 hours
into it I expect this is not just a
small project okay so let let's kind of
maybe read this uh I'm kind of
interested to read this with these
larger projects in general I feel like
I'm not going to be able to look through
every line of code so looking at higher
level things like this might actually be
more helpful especially to the broader
audience that's kind of My Hope and
that's why I'm focusing on this rather
than immediately cloning it and just
running through the thousands of lines
of code so the engine calls the only one
update and one start method of the game
club I'm guessing this person is isn't
an English native speaker I apologize
profusely if they are the engine calls
uh one upd and one star method of the
game class if you create a new script
you need to call the update method from
the script in the game class I mean why
I don't like that if I'm understanding
this correctly it seems like you need to
manually call the update method from the
script in the game class so this is
already a bit of a conflict of design
here because if we have a game class
that is presumably part of the engine
because it's like the central game
Runner kind of class I'm I'm assuming
then the fact that we need to modify the
engine code when we do something as
simple as creating a script which is
clearly on the game side of things this
is already not a good design because the
core engine should be treating the game
scripts as just data meaning that they
are kind of like an asset that the game
has the core should simply load that
data and then in this case with the
scripts simply execute the update
function within the scripts it's the
fairly simple concept of just having a
core engine and Associated data/ assets
that the core will simply load and then
use so this is already not very good now
if you are inspired by these code
reviews and you want to improve your
programming then there's an excellent
free way you can do that with the
sponsor of today's video brilliant.org
brilliant.org is an amazing website
filled with lots and lots of excellent
highquality courses on various stem
topics computer science and math both
extremely important for the world of
programming and Brilliant has excellent
courses on both of those topics and
their courses specifically why I love
them so much is because they're
extremely visual engaging and
interactive they're just honestly a loot
of fun to get through and they're not
too long or anything you can just get
through them if you have only a little
bit of spare time their range of math
courses is so huge they've got
everything from the entry level Everyday
Math course which is a great way to ease
into math all the way to stuff like
calculus which is a really useful if
you're making games and game Dimensions
but also quite difficult but taught by
brilliant it's just become so much
easier to learn because as you probably
noticed from all this footage they have
these widgets you can play with so you
can visually see how things work and
they'll quiz you to make sure that
you're retaining and actually
remembering learning the information
they're trying to teach you now the best
thing about brilliant is you can get
started for free they have a 30-day free
trial that you can use to check out
their entire platform and try out some
of their courses and if you do go on to
like them brilliant have been nice
enough to offer the first 200 of you 20%
off an annual membership huge thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this video if
you want to share instances simply pass
them in the update method or set a
pointer to it in the start method
instances of what exactly scripts again
this is this is involving a lot of uh
you know modification of the of the of
the core engine it's possible that the
game class could be game side I mean I
don't know yet I haven't looked at the
architecture but it's possible that it
could be game side in which case that
might be better but still not preferable
because the dream situation here which
I'm sure most people would probably
realize is that I simply have scripts
and whatever scripts are part of the
game just magically will function and
work without having to go into C++ code
and start calling them uh directly as
function calls you can get access to a
Sprite by calling this config pointer
Sprites get Sprite with name okay this
method Returns the pointer to the Sprite
in the Sprite repository now you're able
to do all kinds of things with the
Sprites please know the engine does
still have a lot of bugs you stop by
downloading the engine here find
introduction to the engine on YouTube
okay so there's a full-on like 25 minute
introduction video which is pretty cool
create a project in the folder open the
exe create a new project by clicking on
the create button so the XT is probably
some kind of launcher that we saw that I
noticed inside the the YouTube video
file dialogue will open select where you
letter you this isn't texting mate if
you're writing a read me you should
probably write proper words want to
create the project and hit the plus
button all the all the files from the
template folder will be automatically
copied in location by the way if you
want to hit build or Str B I'm guessing
that's control that rings a bell from
like German keyboards I remember back
that what does that mean yeah okay it's
German
for and is what the quot yeah yeah I
remember that I went to school in
Germany for a while so control B the
engine the EXC will automatically build
into a folder oh by the way there comes
the English not native language
probably so so you don't need to worry
about messing around with resources DLS
well that's good how do I script my
Sprites right click the hierarchy window
and select new Sprite in the game engine
you can right click on the asset folder
and select new SE plus script so we have
uh separate Sprite and a script at the
moment and this will contain new script
containing the update and startop
functions eventually the script which
gets created out of date you can find
the docs blah blah blah so you can
create a new Sprite pointer in your
class so this again is kind of very C+
plusy we have this game class which
we're manually kind of adding a Sprite
pointer too and then
we're I don't like this design already
and I'll I'll explain why in a minute I
just want to read through the rest of
this first you can give the Sprite
pointer and address by calling get
Sprite by name get the Sprite pointer an
address in search for the Sprite with a
name name this will turn null pointer
with the address to this Sprite so I
definitely don't like the way that you
are just simply storing memory addresses
of Sprites inside the game class finally
you can change the properties of the
Sprite using the update function for
example okay so this is I guess if this
is so what about the script does the
script not run for the Sprite is this
the script this is looks like a it's
like a main game class and then if we
hold the a key then in this case we can
just transform this price position sure
how does price get managed all Sprites
are getting managed by an object called
Sprite repository it contains a private
list of Sprites you can add Sprites to
the scene okay so this I mean this
doesn't look like an anti component
system we'll look at the diagram here in
a minute as well so here we're seeing uh
a new Sprite being created so game
starts and we're creating a new Sprite
by just calling new Sprite so memory
management
there's going to be a lot to talk about
there immediately because this is
definitely not optimal or not how I
would do things and then we have inside
config we're accessing pointer Sprites
which is some kind of collection of
Sprites and we're adding this Sprite to
it I'm assuming that's handing off the
ownership of the Sprite and its
allocated memory into this pointer
Sprites and it might get released this
is okay oh my gosh there's so much to
say see this is the thing about code
reviews I like picking simple projects
because I can just complete them within
140 minute video and that's kind of it
this I could come in and give weeks
worth of consultancy for probably as
well as valid strategies for how you
would fix this and more importantly
something I feel may actually be more
beneficial to viewers of this video and
a lot of my videos in general is why
this is specifically not very good and
how now we can improve it in a kind of
high level potentially actionable way
that isn't specific to this project so
I'm going to do my best in this video to
again not be too roasty even though I
was asked to roast as much as I can and
then we'll just end up seeing how far we
manag to get with the potential
possibility of future videos on this
topic I'm just going to keep reading
this and we'll get back to my my
thoughts on this in a minute so it
basically adds it to a system that will
process the Sprite accordingly we can
activate n components such as setting
collider do exist true this is already
incorrect pseudo code because you have a
pointer so you can't have a DOT here
you'd be using an arrow probably to have
basic Collision detection here's a
simple image showing how the Sprite
repository works it seems like there's a
lot of emphasis on the Sprite repository
considering it's the only arcitectural
diagram in this read me so I'm going to
assume that that I mean this is it is
called Sprite engine so I'm assuming
that this is just the main type of data
we we have here so we have an instance
of config which contains a pointer to
the Sprite reposit itory the user
project contains Sprites and then we
have read and WR an array of Sprites
here this looks like it was made in
paint as well like you got the the it's
like the paint bucket tool was used for
the background but you can see that
there's white in between the letters
because those areas weren't filled in
and we have an array of Sprites here and
then I guess this is the engine which
has an instance of the Sprite repository
but also the a config has a pointed to
the Sprite repository is the config part
of the engine okay and then we just the
processing here we have an array of
sprite we read right here and then I'm
interested to see what this array of
sprit is if it's like a vector if it's a
custom data structure this must be the
equivalent of some sort of entity
component system for this particular
engine because Sprites seem like the
like you don't create an entity or you
don't create a game object you create a
Sprite that is what you do and then you
can assign Behavior to that Sprite
either directly or by creating some form
of external script I imagine which will
contain like an update and a start
function that acts on a Sprite so Sprite
is the the equivalent of an entity as
you would typically find in modern game
engines with an ECS based system so what
exactly is so bad about this design and
why don't I like it pointers let's talk
about the pointer aspect of this
pointers are things numbers Ines that
simply hold and provide an address of
memory a memory address and they're
interesting because beginners are taught
to somewhat avoid them intermediate
programmers learn to embrace them and
they just love using them and they feel
like they're real grown-ups who can use
pointers now and so they literally show
no fear and then experts or experienced
programmers for the most part avoid them
and so it's like this weird bell curve
of like how much are Pointers used
directly and it's you know beginners are
here intermediates are here and experts
are here now realistically experts are
probably here because pointers are
extremely useful and when you're
programming actual memory related things
then of course you're going to use
pointers and you should but we're not
talking about memory systems here we're
talking about objects you know instances
of classes here that are the fundamental
building blocks of our games for that
you should never use pointers and I
think in this video where this is
probably all we'll talk about because I
want to explain this properly if we just
take a moment and we think about what a
pointer means we know that it's a Memory
address we just talked about that and
you probably know what that is from your
own experience I assume there's a lot of
meaning behind what looks like a fairly
simple phrase of creating a Sprite
pointer variable and then assigning it
to a new Sprite the first thing that's
happening here with this phrase is we
are allocating a block of memory that is
going to hold whatever the contents of
that Sprite class happen to be all of
its members all of the amount of space
that that will take up that will be
stored inside a continuously allocated
block of memory which will exist in a
fixed point Point inside your memory
until it is freed or deallocated we're
then assigning it to a variable that is
the appropriate type which is just a
Sprite pointer now you can technically
assign it to other things the real type
of new Sprite is in fact a Sprite
pointer there's no doubt about that but
there are classes inside the C++
standard Library which can accept a
Sprite pointer or any kind of pointer as
an argument in their Constructors and
what that means is that we can take this
same block of code but then assign it to
something like a unique pointer or a
shared pointer what that does is it
doesn't change the allocation at all it
doesn't change this part of the equation
I it's getting very messy here but what
it is doing is adding extra
functionality to what happens with this
memory address specifically such as
adding extra code to process it that
might mean that it gets free read at the
end of a scope which would be the case
with a unique pointer so we've really
broken this down but in this case it's
just stored as a Sprite pointer it is
then added into what looks like a list
of some sort of Sprites of sprite
pointers specifically and so what we
have here is a collection of sprite
pointers which we could assume is some
sort of vector so we're dealing with
something like this this over here is a
collection that's storing all of these
pointers now the interesting thing about
this solution is that it's going to work
I've seen much worse as an example one
thing that is definitely worse and in
fact won't work and will probably end up
crashing your game/ engine is if you try
and allocate this in place so one of the
optimizations that I see quite a lot is
which fundamentally is in fact an
optimization and like rightly so that
people are thinking about it is well
it's annoying that you're having to
construct this memory over here and then
push back a pointer to this block of
memory into your collection why not just
create it directly within the memory
that is allocated for the collection so
in other words if we had a vector of
Sprites that let's just say is this
continuous block of memory over here
instead of us simply storing an 8 by
pointer in all of these cells so this
here is really just a representation of
what this would look like in memory and
then each of these is going to point to
some completely unique and unrelated
block of memory elsewhere instead of us
doing that maybe you should just store a
Sprite in all of these and a Sprite
might be bigger than 8 byes I don't know
how big it is in this engine could be
like 50 bytes or something whatever but
the idea is when I iterate through this
that might in fact be an optimization
and iterating through Sprites very very
common very necessary I want to render
all these Sprites how am I going to do
that well I need to iterate through them
and I'm obviously talking about simpler
engines here such as this one if you had
a more advanced engine then you might
not just have a global collection of
Sprites you might have some sort of
petitioning system the design there is
going to be more complicated but in this
case we just have a global list of
Sprites that is literally stored in like
the game class or the config inside the
main engine I mean this isn't even
divided into scenes which is another
thing I was going to talk about it it
literally is just a global pool of
Sprites so that would be an optimization
because if we go through that Vector of
Sprites inside this for Loop we now no
longer have to retrieve the actual spr
right pointer from elsewhere in memory
which means that again our memory
reading is being redirected there's this
first part of having to retrieve the
vector memory but then once you're
inside the vector you have to go
elsewhere to get the memory for that
particular Sprite because if you have
pointers they're all pointing somewhere
else so that part is optimized because
to get that Sprite memory well it's
already here each one of these elements
is already a Sprite but then what I've
seen people do is they still need to
access it like this because they want to
make individual changes to the Sprite so
what they tend to do is get pointers to
the memory inside the vector and so you
can do that in two ways you can either
just actually get a Sprite pointer or
you can get a Sprite reference there's
no difference between these two
references are just pointers they just
have different semantics when you use
them inside C++ and in this case there
is no difference with what I'm about to
say and the way you get that is you can
simply ask the vector hey give me like
element two please
and I'm going to go ahead and this is
probably going to be very hard to watch
cuz it's on it's diagonal I apologize
for that you know give me this Sprite
Which might be the memory address of
that or if you wanted to use a reference
you know you'd have a reference just
simply like that and then you might want
to store that somewhere and do whatever
you want with it it might be harder to
store references but you can obviously
store pointers as if they were normal
variables so what is the issue exactly
with that because it seems like an
optimization and you might even consider
suggesting that to someone who is
instead instead creating individual
Sprites by using the new keyword and
then storing them in a collection which
adds that further layer of interaction
the problem is that this memory is not
fixed which in turn means that these
things here which are just memory
addresses they're not identifiers to
Sprites and I think that's really the
core underlying issue here the fact that
when you store a Sprite reference or a
Sprite pointer in fact any kind of
reference or pointer you are simply
storing the address of that data in
memory as it stands right now in this
moment game engines are complicated
applications complicated applications
which might for further optimization or
just out of necessity really reallocate
existing memory somewhere else so as an
example what if I want to add a fifth
Sprite here and we don't have room
because this is the entirety of that
contiguous allocation well we need to
find a new block of memory and we need
to resize and grow the vector it is
possible that it might be able to do
some sort of realic and simply grow the
existing memory whilst keeping the same
address but you're probably going to end
up with a completely different block of
memory that is now bigger able to house
your extra Sprites what that means is
that any reference you had to that
Sprite so either an actual literal
reference or a pointer is now completely
invalid it's now pointing to memory that
has been freed you have an invalid
pointer and if you try and access read
right to that memory you're probably
going to crash in fact crash would be
the preferable thing here because the
other option might be you're overwriting
other memory that you didn't mean to
touch or you're reading garbage so in
actual fact it's really dangerous to
Simply take pointers or references to
elements inside a vector and instead
what you should do is anytime you want
to use or reference an element within
that Vector you should use this directly
because if you always simply write
Vector at element 2 you will always
always get the third element inside the
vector without worrying about oh yeah
but has has that Vector grown you know
has it reallocated its an internal
memory a detail that you should never
care about now if we continue breaking
this down and we take a look at what the
heck two means because I think that's an
important thing to to look at we've
solved one problem because we're still
doing the thing where we are storing all
of the Sprites themselves in contiguous
memory instead of pointers to additional
blocks of memory so this is still a good
thing but we lose the ability to Simply
refer to them like this as a Sprite
pointer which by the way bit of a
disclaimer of course you can still do
that with a vector I'm just saying that
you should be careful about it and you
probably shouldn't do it too much in
fact if I was being really pedantic and
careful I wouldn't do it at all because
whilst it might be okay in a scope such
as this if you end up storing that
anywhere it might work for the time
being but then depending on how the
vector is used and when your engine
grows it can lead to hard to find bugs
and we've had some of them in in my
Hazel engine as well because this
doesn't just apply to vectors like these
ones taking references and pointers in
general might be difficult if their
underlying memory and storage pool is
being modified between you using those
pointers or references so we have made
an improvement but now every time we
want that Sprite instead of just being
able to store it as a pointer we now
have to use this mysterious number two
this isn't really great now what we
could do though is we could give it a
name this is a very simple programming
tactic that we have if we have a
variable why just write two all the time
if I can instead give it some kind of
name such as Sprite and then what does
that mean that means that when I write
vector and instead of writing two I now
write Sprite so it's kind of cool
because it's like I've taken this name I
mean it was spr here but I've taken this
name and I've given it the value two and
now I have a way of giving a name to the
exact data that I want to access instead
of it being up Charly to and it still
works with the rest of the system which
is great and what have we done really
well we've created some form of an ID
haven't we we have an integer that
defines a particular set of data that we
would like to access which is our Sprite
and it will remain here forever the only
the only reason why it wouldn't is if
you delete it if this Vector gets
completely deleted if you move or
rearrange the Sprites like as an example
if instead of push back to Vector you
were doing push front or something or if
you swap out that index that element
inside the vector specifically of course
you're going to lose the data but if you
just let it exist as is then of course
it's always going to be index 2 it's not
going to have the same problem of well I
was holding a reference or a pointer but
that was a memory address and the memory
got reallocated so now I've lost it no
you're always going to have a valid ID
to that Sprite now in more complicated
systems you need to be careful with this
which is why we generally use things
called uu IDs universally unique
identifiers which are the same well
depending on who you are and depending
in which context you use them they're
basically the same things as globally
unique identifiers and what those are
are typically could be anything from in
my mind could be anything from a 64-bit
at least probably to 128 bit 26 whatever
bit integer that is supposedly globally
unique or universally unique meaning
that there's very very little chance for
a conflict if you generate one of these
so as an example let's just say we have
a 64-bit uuid which is currently what
Hazel users for all of its identifiers
if I randomly generate a number that is
obviously if it's unsigned 2 ^ of 64 is
the range there so this is kind of the
range of numbers that I'm generating and
I'm just randomly going to come up with
a number in that range very very
unlikely that I'm going to get any kind
of conflict and it means that I don't
have a simple ascending index that might
not work because if you needed to have
an identifier that was unique across
scenes this is a very simple case but
let's just say you have two scenes
inside your game you have like even a
main menu scene and then you have the
actual game scene and then you're
referring to everything as Sprites
because well you have Sprites in all of
them you have some Sprites in the main
menu have some Sprites in your game if
you just have an ascending index that
just goes 0 1 2 3 4 then as those two
scenes are being built you're going to
run into conflicts and if you do still
maintain a global Vector of Sprites as
you're doing here and just whatever we
have multiple scenes but there's still a
global list of spres well what happens
if there's someone else on the team
working on this project they're
obviously creating new Sprites which
means that they're getting an ascending
index index 5 for example but then what
if you also create a new Sprite then
both of you have created Sprite number
five and that's going to be a conflict
but if you randomly generate a 64-bit
unsigned integer they're going to have
completely different numbers I can
almost guarantee it I don't remember
what the exact probability of a
collision there is generating the exact
same number but maybe someone in the
comments wants to point it out so this
is really the preferred way to do this
but at the very least what I've
hopefully shown you is that in instead
of trying to refer to these Sprites as
pointers to blocks of memory that are
either very fragmented meaning that
every time you add a new Sprite you
allocate a block of memory somewhere
else inside your RAM which again you
don't want to do for the sake of how
memory Works in general and how it's
faster to retrieve cached memory but
also you avoid using the memory address
as an identifier which as we've talked
about is not a good thing to do and then
actually uh one thing one critical thing
that I probably didn't mention about
this uh because I I wasn't really
thinking about using memory as an
identifier per se even though that that
is kind of what you're doing is that you
can't serialize that obviously like if
you want to save that Sprite you need a
way of identifying it that isn't its
memory address because the memory
address is going to be different every
time you run and it's not going to make
too much sense to do this but if you
just simply have an ID even something as
simple as two or better yet a uu ID or a
or a goid you're going to end up with a
much more powerful way to identify that
Sprite Which will obviously be
persistent globally and you won't have
any problem s with that but at the very
least you could switch to using
something like an index which is going
to give you a whole range of benefits
now dealing with it as a specific
integer like if you if you just store
integers there was this example over
here where you're storing a Sprite if
you just change this to be an INT M
Sprite you might not like that because
you lose out on some of the
functionality meaning that you can just
do something like M sprite.
transform.position dox and that might be
something that you like doing versus if
it's just an integer you having to
retrieve the Sprite from the vector
first like this and then on this object
having to use well if it's just a uh a
list of Sprites like that you know dot
transform or whatever but that's not
really a problem because you can still
create a Sprite class so you have your
class called Sprite here but then
internally it can have that ID which is
really an index into where it's stored
and then as long as it has some way to
reach that Vector so as an example you
might give it some sort of reference to
the s or to your config with or to your
Sprites vector or whatever then you can
still write all of your functions around
that I mean it would have to be a
function it wouldn't just be do
transform but inside this Sprite class
you could have a function as an example
you know called transform which when
it's called will just go into that
Vector at the index that you have over
here find the Sprite and then give you
that transform and that's what it would
return and then of course you'd return
like a reference to it or something and
then you would you'd have to add like
the little parentheses here but the
functionality would kind of more or less
be the same and you could still store
Sprite here but the idea is you're not
storing a Sprite pointer you're storing
a Sprite object which is that identifier
you know you've kind of wrapped the
fundamental underlying identifier that
lets you access that particular data
with functions that go in and and do
that accessing for you and again all
that does is it just gives you a little
bit more API design to hopefully make
your code look nicer because you you
don't have to go into the underlying
data structure to retrieve the data that
you're interested in reading or writing
as I mentioned earlier the other huge
issue with this is that this is your
game class and then the way you create
Sprites is just you just do new Sprite
and you're putting it into the config
which just has a collection of Sprites
what about a context for these Sprites
to exist in like some kind of world a
scene is basically what I'm talking
about in pretty much all game engines
and even in non like entity component
system based engines even back in the
day everything still revolves around the
concept of having a scene or some sort
of equivalent where everything lives so
all of your game World lives within a
scene which includes all of the Sprites
all of the different entities that might
play audio or have some sort of behavior
attached to them they all live within a
scene and that is so important because
what it does is it semantically ties the
lifetime of these I don't know assets or
actors or whatever to this scene and why
is that important because games
typically have more than one scene and
it wouldn't be efficient or even
functional to Simply store the entire
game inside memory at all times and so
if you create all of your essentially
entities within a scene you can simply
move from one scene to the next scene
and then all of this just gets dropped
immediately like that because the
lifetime is tied to the scene and you
can begin loading whatever might belong
to this scene so the fact that again you
spent 2,000 hours on an engine but you
don't seem to have the concept of scenes
is a little rough to be honest I would
have expected something like this and
again it doesn't have to follow you know
you might be trying to make something a
bit more unique and of course you are
potentially going to have assets that
are shared between scenes so you might
need more complicated lifetime models
than just simply a scene contains
everything and that's it but that is
still something very important and I
would say that these Sprites that you're
storing here should be contextually
residing with in some sort of scene
maybe you could have a scene which owns
a list or collection of Sprites as an
example okay I think I'm going to stop
the video here let me know your thoughts
about what I was talking about I hope
that this was helpful to some of you as
well as the author of this engine I
haven't even opened this engine in
Visual Studio we've been on the GitHub
read me this entire video which I
honestly did not expect before I started
the video I went ahead and cloned the
repository so we'd be ready to go and we
didn't even progress past the GitHub
read me which is amazing if you would
like to see me continue on with this
engine let me know in the comment
section below as well as if you liked
this idea of me drawing stuff and
explaining things in a little bit more
depth My Hope Is that this is more
helpful than just me talking and looking
at code and giving commentary so please
let me know if you liked this if you
would like me to review a code go ahead
and send it into Channel review
gmail.com there will be some
instructions in the description of this
video we might be stuck on this project
for a while but it's always good to send
in your code because you might be next
don't forget to check out brilliant. /
the CH link will be in description below
and I will see you guys next time
goodbye